good morning believe nation today's
message is win no matter what
over to you DJ Khaled you small you very
small we the best you a genius I
appreciate you you loyal I've changed a
lot you can to win win win no matter
what then the doors that was closed I
ripped the doors off and took the hinges
off and when I took the hinges off
I put the hinges in the boys ends yeah
in the boy hands you know I took the
whole door off from the hinges and I put
it in the boys hands you could put the
hinges on the hands too never give up
never surrender so what do you think I
think winning is more perspective or a
frame of mind because you get to define
success for yourself right if you fail
or if a business fails or something
falls flat or falls through if you learn
something you can call that a win like
it depends right it depends on what's
important to you and what you take from
it but either way it's important you
make sure that in life things are coming
up as a win for you or you're able to
see them as a win for you yeah I think
it's easy to think about winning as only
your professional goals right like I'm
gonna win in business I'm gonna get a
million dollars or whatever it is where
when it could be a lot more winning
could be I want to be a great husband I
want to be a good father I want to be a
great friend and all of that combined it
doesn't have to come out of sacrifice
right it doesn't have to be well in
order to get rich and do well in
business I have to suck as a family
person as well right depending on what's
most important to you achieving those
goals is winning and for me what I took
from it
is not letting you know the little voice
in your head hold you back not letting
the excuses hold you back not letting
the people around you say you can't do
it hold you back or I think that's most
people as you set a goal and then the
people around you or you yourself say
this isn't gonna work I can't do this
I'm and really just you're afraid you're
afraid of taking action you're afraid of
taking that next step you're afraid of
how you're gonna be judged and so
pushing through all those voices pushing
throughout all that negativity and
moving forward and actually going out
and accomplishing your goal stop just
saying you're gonna do something and
start taking steps to actually do it so
the question today today is what can you
see as a win today I like it I like it
leave in the comments will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
you